nous sommes à bellingham 90 mille
résidents et une clinique d'avortement
en 1970 l'état de washington a été le
premier aux états unis à protéger le
droit à l'avortement
la semaine dernière marie sam à kraft a
organisé une manifestation de 500
personnes en faveur de l'avortement
quelques heures seulement après avoir
entendu que la cour suprême pour élever
la protection du droit à l'avortement
militants et politicien démocrate de
l'état de washington ont sorti leurs
valeurs attaquées washington state
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et le gouverneur de l'état a de suite
annoncé que l'état de washington
deviendrait un refuge pour toutes les
femmes qui auraient besoin de recourir à
un avortement sans attendre les
résultats du vote de la cour suprême
cette clinique commence déjà à se
préparer à recevoir les clientes des
états voisins comme la barre haut et le
montana les états qui pourraient
interdire l'avortement en tout plus de
la moitié des états américains
pourraient limiter ou interdire
l'avortement si le jugement ou au
contraire wade est invalidée
la clinique de bellingham cherche déjà
de nouveaux médecins et le financement
des avortements pour les femmes venues
d'autres états commencent à s'organiser
[Musique]
à l'hôtel de ville de bellingham une
conseillère municipale craint
particulièrement pour le bien-être des
femmes de couleur qui statistiquement
sont celles qui utilisent le plus les
services d'avortement aux états unis
elle est la première conseillère
municipale noir élu à bellingham
face à une cour suprême majoritairement
républicaine le mouvement pro avortement
craint que d'autres changements sont à
venir
marisa malgrave compte continuer à
mobiliser les militants pour tenter
d'influencer le vote de la cour suprême
qui pourrait se tenir dans les deux
prochains mois ici bonne offert à dîner
à le canada bellingham dans l'état de
washington